[ENGINE SOUNDS]
LEWIS HAMILTON:
When I was four, five years old,
I either wanted to be Superman
or I wanted to be a Formula
One world champion.
When my visor comes down,
that's when my mind definitely
switches to a different
capacity, and it's high-octane.
As an athlete, I'm always
looking how I can be better.
I'm going to be talking to you about
mental preparation,
how you can be laser-focused,
and have more energy.
How you can feel healthier,
because the better you feel,
the better you are
at doing your job.
You might already be successful.
Killing it in whatever you're doing
but I can help you be better.
My mastery is not the ability
to put the car on the limit.
[ENGINE ROARING]
It's mastering my emotions
and understanding
how to live into my potential.
[TIRES SCREECHING]
I will show you what is possible.
This is MasterClass.